we spoke to Turkey and he went through a
system and we got him out they've been
trying to get him out for a long time
well this has nothing to do with
anything there was no deal made at all
there was no deal but we're very happy
to have him and have him in good shape I
hear he's in very good shape
all right that was President Trump
earlier tonight talking about the
release of American pastor Andrew
Brunson joining us now on the phone from
the American Center for Law and Justice
also the president's attorney and also
at times he's been mine
Jay Sekulow you have worked on this case
Jay from the very beginning I know how
hard you work I know how hard the
president has worked on this this is
great news tonight now this is a big win
and you know it was funny when you did
the introduction I feel like I'm
representing everybody tonight but what
a great day it is for the Brunson family
and for Pastor Brunson himself and the
president and the administration did
just a phenomenal job in moving this
case forward you know
sterling I'm handled a lot of these and
the fact is they're difficult there are
times when there's progress and there's
time when they're not this was even more
complicated because it was a NATO ally
but the end result of it and the
positive aspect of this is that the
pastor has been released unconditionally
and is on route they already blended in
Germany and will be coming back to the
United States as early as tomorrow so
this is a great win and again a huge
thank you to the president of the
administration to end to members one
point okay but the president really led
the charge here to get this done and I
really appreciate it so okay and there
was no deal and the charge for pastor
Brunson was he was preaching the gospel
right yes I mean actually the indictment
itself has the word it's a Turkish of
course but it's called Christianisation
and that is they view that act of
running the small starts sharing the
gospel as an act that was an act of
terrorism that's how they define it this
was a terrorist case believe it or not
but again the great news is he's been
released he's been returned I appreciate
you covering it and again appreciate all
the work that the president
did it it getting this accomplished for
the family alright Jay Sekulow I know
you've been working on this since the
beginning congratulations president also
great job